hang on you guys Jackie spill do you
okay just spill that myself cuz this cap
it's cuz I don't have a [ __ ] straw
looking you Adrian Grenier taking lives
I think god I'm wearing black but I just
still copy all over myself and honestly
think I do to choke the war on straws
has claimed another victim
well good morning Millennials welcome to
the morning trust the Millennial morning
show how are you doing today good
morning Millennials
I've actually since we last spoke got a
lot of feedback on the chatter and cuz
yesterday's episode I trust one mean
comment we got just like that we talked
too much in the beginning of our show
like that's not celebrity related and I
would say I took it to heart because I
never want to be out of tune which is
what I said yesterday in case you didn't
listen today yesterday's episode and
then Jackie told me not to listen to
that one comment and then everyone
descended upon us like no don't we love
it okay great
but someone did make one interesting
point an interesting factoid that was
well interesting and here's the thing
about that interesting factoid the thing
is they said a lot of times they'll like
try and get their friends to become
toasters and it's hard for them to like
they don't know us like the personal
chatter is irrelevant for now until they
become like interested in us understood
I just think that we should do one
episode of the show that's like meant to
be the one that you used to convert your
friends like you have it already it's
episode where we did the baskets and we
went on and on about all these people
who deserve justice what's their
personal chatter in the beginning I
don't know also number one toaster Liz
heightened has put together a
comprehensive document a Google Doc the
best episode that's episodes for
existing toasters we just do one like
staged episode okay where we just act
like normal people like with the [ __ ]
dis vs no no because I already spilled
and like I'm just look at us we're just
like so laid back with our spillage
we've like much to discuss also you know
what I couldn't something you might have
spray itching your armpit like a monkey
because it's so true do you ever get
really itchy armpits only if I forgot to
wear deodorant
oh if you forget yeah where are my
deodorants not working or sometimes I
really like to scratch my armpit with my
deodorant is that gross yeah but then
I'm getting clean yeah I guess it's
better than scratching it with your
fingernails one time I did like a
nighttime routine on my Instagram like
what I do before bed and honestly I
never really do anything but I just want
to make some content and people called
me out for putting on deodorant before
bed so it's weird but it's not
because technically you shower at 8
o'clock you don't put deodorant on for
the next 12 hours like yeah you're gonna
smell in your sleep but putting all
those chemicals into your body while
you're just resting is a little
unnecessary
I don't put deodorant on before bed but
I don't follow to people who do but like
people who complain about like deodorant
chemicals like really there are people
that are dying okay yeah I don't know
the war on deodorant I'm just oh I'm
totally nuts well we've taken the war on
armpit hair like now you can have it
okay what's next
no children yeah and honestly not that I
really have anything against girls who
grow their armpit hair out like a kind
of you actually but how do you put on
deodorant if you have like big long
strands of hair I mean you could use
men's deodorant
oh yeah but like when Ben put some
deodorant I just don't think it works I
use ax deodorant because female
deodorant doesn't work does that guy
very Orbitz not any more or less hairy
than the average man Ben is above
average when it comes to hair that's why
I ask cuz he has a sweater I catch me he
wears a full-time cashmere sweater I'm
gonna sleep that's why he's always hot
Ben is literally a human furnace like
back waxed 40 on virgins totally
whenever Kelly Clark says he loves his
back hair like he thinks he's a man
here's the Harry Baxter curse but um so
Ben is a human furnace like if I'm
sleeping and I want to turn the heat on
but I don't want to get up like I'm cold
I literally like put my feet like it's a
fire by Ben's shins I'm warm in a second
oh so is Zach and they he's Jacob from
Twilight yes and that is totally Bella
but that's such I'm not Bella cuz like I
sweat a lot if I'm ever cold I am cold
all the time and he's Jacob and it's a
really good analogy analogy it's I mean
just I think we've got every episode to
speak with the Twilight reference oh wow
Oh Jason Kartik is Edward what it was
Monday
I think Jason toxic again wasn't in
doubt whenever you needed Twilight
reference just bring on Jason Karthik
also we have some exciting guest updates
tomorrow we will have four cast members
from siesta key we'll have a pending
that their flight there's suppose to be
some storm whatever we'll say Club Chloe
Juliet Brandon and Garen is that it I
didn't know which of the I only knew
Chloe Angela yeah I like schemed over
the email I saw Chloe enjoy yeah okay
whatever but I believe it's Garrett and
Brandon Brandon Brandon Brandon it seems
highly unnecessary that we have both
hybrids of the name like just we should
have gone with either Brendon or Brandon
but Brandon is
the more used one Linden is randon yeah
Brendon is like the quirky one it's like
the hipster yeah totally so Brendon
branded CSI he hasn't been on in so long
and I'm so excited it's it's similar to
don't be tardy like they put so much
time between these no this is just a
year pretty much but what was weird is
that were scared at the end of last
summer and it got such positive
reception he came back in January so we
assumed we were getting it again at the
end of last year's summer but it we had
to wait a year yeah it's been a year but
they filmed it over the summer oh so
good I think their summer starts in
April it's not like don't be tardy
because it's not weird but I just miss
about the dhobi no Joby tardies now it
got a premiere date in February but it's
like I've been waiting forever and I
think they filmed this like over a year
ago it's like not even relevant anymore
they don't get Bravo just knocking Toby
tardy the respect that it deserves it is
truly the greatest show on television
but a really curious to know what the
highest rated Bravo shows are cuz I
think every show calls itself a cast
member of like a popular show calls
themselves almost like the Phantom hub
rules kids say that they're one of the
most watched shows I believe that the
Real Housewives of Atlanta is actually
the most watched show but they say that
about southern charm they say it about
all about they say that southern charm
they say about married to medicine they
say about better controls they say it
about below deck no they job yes they do
they do yeah that it's like one of the
most by the way I forgot to tell you I
don't know if I ever told you this but
when I went to Miami and I was doing my
me reading my show summer brought me a
gift and it was a copy of captain Lee's
book with his signature inside made out
to both of us
what yeah like her mom knew captain Lee
or something I mean it's not having
sandy but it'll do it'll do okay that'll
do
excuse me my name Mike Myers kick to
Mikey Myers Mike Myers what does that
what did you don't do don't get that
Alou okay by the way that is the worst
truck impersonation it's actually a very
hard to do this your impersonation but I
tell you that I recently watched Trek no
it is the great greatest movie and
honestly it's not made for kids like
there's so many jokes I definitely
didn't understand a lot of Pixar movies
are like that where they have like
innuendos for the adults in the audience
but the kids don't pick up on it no
Shrek is the greatest movie and honestly
like Shrek is a catch he owned that
whole swamp
he's a legit landowner
he's a developer agreed loved him
yeah and also it's like everyone from
that movie oh my god why I'm about to
make the greatest call ever every person
from that movie fell off the face of the
earth Mike Myers Cameron Diaz Eddie
Murphy Murphy literally refuses to work
cuz they all have that check money yeah
I read somewhere Cameron Diaz from the
three franchises and then all the video
games everything should be an 80 mil
that's pretty good now you can retire
she actually like hasn't been seen yeah
and since the other woman I mean what
can you do after that hold it what can
you do after that movie everything else
just pales in comparison it's like you
make Shrek you think I'm never gonna
make a piece of content greater than
this and then someone comes to you with
the film the other woman and then there
you have it damn yeah rips off part of
your head you bring laying on the ground
and little bloody pieces no I asked chef
would you even [ __ ] what kind of pants a
sudden [ __ ] job she was wearing
honestly
I read it I have to stop saying honestly
I read conspiracy theory let me see who
you're being honest I was am probably
lying anyway I read a conspiracy theory
about Marisa Tomei she won an Oscar I'm
not sure if it's for that movie AHA it
is and they thought that that she won
they had like a moonlight moment
moonlight la-la-land but they didn't fix
it and if you watch a footage like it
kind of spooky yeah but I don't want to
take away from she shot yeah right my
cousin Vinnie is the greatest movie ever
I found out over maybe like 1 or 2 years
ago that Ben had never seen my cousin
Vinnie and like we referenced Emily all
the time like we say the deer thing like
it's a very much a part of our family
and I realized he's been like lying all
these years just like nodding his head
Wow watching that he's not being honest
no not a I'm sure but I mean him watch
it obviously he loved it's like him in a
movie I couldn't believe you haven't
seen it I know that's always so great
when you can introduce someone to a
movie and it's like this movie was made
for you know you know yeah like what
movies have I not seen that I would
[ __ ] love well actually now that you
said that last night Ben was again
trying to convince me to watch my race
and he said it's the funniest movie
you've ever seen I said no I've already
seen the funniest people I've ever seen
I don't know what it is but it's not
that you know ya know you'll like it
we've seen it as kids when you see it
nobody moments you're gonna remember I
think there's something in the car I
think I love you like poops out the
window okay I definitely I want to see
that just see it no good right is that
rat race I think so I don't think so
I think you look so lovely today Oh
Gemma knew really and you know what the
juxtaposition of me actually looking
like a boy
it's working yeah I mean it's a co-ed
show have you done the PopSugar twinning
thing no have you yeah I just did it
while I was sitting here before you got
here could you give me Alexa Vega and
honestly in the two pictures I kind of
agreed obviously I agree also then they
gave me Snookie which like people have
been Tony I look like Snuggie for
forever but the picture I used was like
the greatest picture of me and the
picture they use if seunghee was like
not a good one
and to be honest I didn't see the
resemblance anymore and it only said 24
percent okay I'm gonna do it I saw that
snitch didn't she was the queen
elizabeth's small okay I got Elizabeth -
Elizabeth last name is small I guess
that's crazy I know it's very really
similar to Elizabeth Smart I got but I
got Elizabeth too they give you five
options and they go by percentage Alexa
Day was my number one I've got Queen
Elizabeth like ten percent so did
Margaux she just screenshotted that one
she's but it's me what if her higher up
one was Adele and honestly in the
picture I saw it okay it's somebody the
eyeliner and that's what it was it was
like the the really circular eyes with
the eyeliner I'm gonna do it you should
I'm excited they're gonna be like
Jessica chest you see I did the ten year
challenge you did on my Instagram story
what was the picture how did you find a
picture from ten years ago I went on my
facebook I went to an album from my
senior year of high school and even
though that picture oh I'm sorry I did
say sorry and it was you on the balcony
in the white shirt right it was it
wasn't remarkable no the difference is
really just eyebrows yeah it told
anything it just proved that I really
look the same when I've had no work done
then good for you thank you like I've
just it's really hard to maintain like
to look the same people think that you
know yeah that's it's hard saying it's
sister and I've had my ups and downs if
you had if I'd done a nine year
challenge spooky stuff but now like my
hair isn't the same length as it wasn't
that picture it's just I'm coming full
circle some of the comments are saying
there's some schmutz in my hair
honestly today's just not my day okay
can't beat you can't have every day sis
yeah I'm just gonna give up on this week
you know well are you ready for the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast I guess I guess I
want to get through them because there's
much to discuss much suited for children
because by the way when you said much
before I'm like why are you saying it
like that and now I realize because
you're doing it Miss Trunchbull voice
much too good for children when the CEO
stayed with me during nephews weekend
out and it was really cold that weekend
and Claudia was saying they came to the
park this and that I was like
it is so cold outside it's much too cold
for Tiggy and then much and she has very
big teeth in the front and they got too
good for children I'm gonna say that
movie is so good and you know what's
even better the Broadway play have you
seen it no oh my god phenomenal I've
seen it twice and the first time I saw
it been literally like out front-row
tickets and that's when we realized like
Pharmacy said a Broadway show is like
the worst seat in the house next season
not only that next season but we were so
close to the girl playing Matilda and we
were so confused because she literally
had like in the middle of her forehead
like coming down from her hair like a
testicle like that's what we kept saying
it looked like two little balls and we
were like so confused like it was so
weird and we just didn't know it turns
out it was her microphone and that's why
I never want to say forever god I don't
need to see the actors testicles oh my
god moving on okay people are saying
there's still something middle top left
you see everything my hair NATO top left
hold on no but let me maybe it's just
like a light reflection maybe okay oh
it's a piece of glitter how exciting
it's on the left side of my head turn
turn and I'll two ways from wow it's
such a big secret around one like I
think I know what is yeah I'm saying yes
okay these are all over my kitchen floor
now I made a mistake so I'm going to
Mexico to speak and I got the itinerary
and there's like a couple of themed
nights and I'm not gonna lie when I read
it for the first time I was a little
drunk at dinner and I just ordered
clothes online it said disco so I
ordered like cheesy ass disco white
boots like sparkly dress with the long
sleeves then the next day I realized it
says disco sequin I mean attire is
sequins so everything I bought it was
useless so I got this cheesy like
Halloween dress in the mail yesterday
from Amazon then I'm not gonna wear but
I just tried it on and I look terrible
in it anyway they sent it back got it
well that explains the sequin yeah I
mean worst things to have in your hair
honestly okay like how glamorous mi
totally first story The Bachelor is
called an Underwood opens up about his
first love Aly Raisman
so he went on lady game podcast which I
hope it wasn't on the show versions on
the podcast version so now I have to
listen to a podcast and unfortunately
but you know what I'll do it for premium
content and the ladies asked about the
former football players worst heartbreak
and he confirmed that it was not on the
show quote while it was confusing and
hard in the beginning it also taught me
a lot of
myself what I need what I want what I
can do better in a relationship he said
of his time together with Riesman it was
a big step for me it was really tough it
all began when the 26 year old recorded
a video to congratulate her on her
accomplishments at the 2016 Rio Olympics
Underwood play for the Oakland Raiders
at the same time and was on the same
team as former gymnast Shawn Johnson's
husband and Ruiz that's still my
favorite part of every I remember when
he made this video asking her out and
like she was so key with her hava nagila
routine and like this well well play I
really appreciated her oh my god I
forgot about her hava nagila routine
after we go to her cover this story
let's just talk about Aly Raisman I just
love her quote my roommates my teammates
everybody over here is super proud of
you he said in the video to the 24 year
old Underwood then asked her an
open-ended offer that worked into some
cute Twitter flirting if you're ever in
San Jose and want to go on a double date
he trailed off and then she responded at
him thanks for the sweet video looking
forward to meeting you I mean that's so
cute honestly like I ship them even
though it didn't work out I just I feel
like Ali Raisman is like slowly dying
inside that like Colton is doing this I
know because clearly like it definitely
didn't end well he like lied on The
Bachelor about never having a meeting a
girl's family brought a girl home yeah
there he wasn't one's easy right the
racemate family you look can't lie in
this day and age like you just had to
learn that but I love him I love her and
now that he's like a big star in his own
right like maybe they could give it
another go no but like Aly Raisman is
like an American she's honestly like an
American icon I know she's an American
night it's really crazy that he is about
her and they really managed to
circumvent the Ali brace 'men of it all
right like she's never mentioned they
used to walk red carpets together they
went to the Golden Globes together Wow
and like he looks like so nerdy he looks
so young yeah and like it was before he
got hooked up with The Bachelor Taylor
because he looks like just like a
football player a little long in a Miss
suit no totally but like I don't know
Ali raised me to me is like at a level
of prestige that The Bachelor could only
dream of attaining so I'm really
actually glad they've kept her out of
this like please she's been through
enough and she doesn't need this trash
no offense like I don't need to be
watching a reality show that reali
raisin is on or even spoken about you
know I agree I'm glad that they've kept
her out of it but it's always just nice
to come back to it and now that I love
Colton even more
they ever have now I just I'd look at
their relationship through different
eyes except when Nastya was here and we
asked her about him she was like not
here for what oh yeah like I think they
probably ended badly yeah they're all
team Ally over there yeah but they're
also Team USA also I just it proves that
I can't even speak today
it proves that Colton is really good
taste in women cuz like he likes a nice
Jewish girl who dances to Hava Nagila
right speaking of oh my god we recorded
a patreon episode yesterday maybe one of
my favorite pick up a besides we've done
yet
where we literally just put the
recorders down and me Jackie and Margo
sat on my couch and we made Margo a
dating app profile she's never been on
any of those apps and like homegirl
needs to get it a it's sorry and she's
beautiful woman like why not so we put
together a profile we curated all the
photos answered all the questions and
started swiping and it was the most fun
I've ever had I never got to do any of
those apps as a child so I'm Margo said
I could download the app and like do it
for her but she needs to get excited you
guys should listen and she promised that
she was gonna go on one date by the end
of January she sent me like a screenshot
of something last night like proving
that she was on the app like at least
she's playing around okay okay cool
yeah and I think she saw like some
really like good contenders oh my god
they were seen so gently inspired her
that there's that there could be like
someone out there for her that she might
actually be interested in meeting
Britain they think there's a stigma like
if you're annotating up you're the worst
of the worst and you can't find anyone
no it's just normal now and I think she
was surprised to see like young cute
accomplished smart guys Harvard men we
saw Harvard and Duke Harvard men like I
guess people could just lie Oh totally I
mean we kind of lied on Margot's no
actually we didn't know we never did
what's why about she's a tour manager
who's a student yeah
very odd be looking like this [ __ ]
like we need to set up a photo shoot for
her for like some tasteful photos well
that was the hard part is like you want
to had a combination if you have every
picture in a bathing suit like the boys
just gonna think you're a [ __ ] and
honestly he's probably right but like if
every pictures in Vegas he thinks you're
not serious so we had to do a
combination of like relaxed calm photos
but also like party Margo has a great
body we want to show off her body
homegirl had not one nice photo no next
time we go it's like to dinner with her
I'm bringing my collared shirt and I
really like my professional camera okay
you ready for the next story we're
breathing through because there's so
much to discuss I need to just talk
about fire festival for like a [ __ ]
hour okay
next up Rihanna is suing her dad
Ronald's family for trying to cash in on
her Fame by using their family name to
brand his entertainment business oh my
god shook in legal papers the pop star
says her dad is trying to profit from
her fame further alleges he and business
partner have been soliciting business by
falsely acting as her agent he is said
to have booked her on a 15 million
dollar tour in Latin America and to
concerts the Staples Center
she wants damages from her father and an
injunction on his business I guess the
name of the business is fancied
entertainment and also lucky was talking
if your own the Staples Center and
you're talking to Rihanna's dad you're
assuming he's definitely on the team you
know right that's great and he's ray
honest dad on behalf of fenty
entertainment like I have to say and
weirdly enough the whole world revolves
around keke palmer cuz I heard keke
palmer in an interview once like many
many years ago and she said something
that was so true and really resonated
with me she was like when you get famous
and you get like you make so much money
like your family becomes weird and
that's proof like can you imagine like
you booking tours for snitch or
something like that's crazy like when
there's fifteen million dollars on the
line Oh Michael I maybe I would do it
right and like what's his plan this is
very Billy McFarland of him oh my god
totally what was his plan for two nights
at the Staples Center like who's gonna
show up honestly like he should have
just contacted me and I would have
gotten my bags up you could get a a
Rihanna impersonator just like clear and
thigh high boots in a trench coat boom
yuri onna that is so crazy I mean
obviously she'll win and good for her
but like to even him to deal with this
sort of like family drama I'm such a
public forum are you crying no I'm
literally like I just cry something in
my check II just said her friends
reference he's gonna well you cried I
know there's something in my eye and
like you wouldn't talk no I mean I'm
just feeling like really upset that my
sister doesn't want friends I mean if
you need someone to talk about it I'm
here for you I'm okay but they I've been
thinking a lot about a conversation
yesterday cuz I was telling you how like
I was so good all day oh my god this
[ __ ] thing about I sorry I was like
so good all day two days ago and then I
look on Tibet and ate so much Chinese
spending like undid my whole day and I
just thinking about you a lot I really
yea like cuz we're talking that
SoulCycle like I'm not that I'm it's
gonna happen like I'm thinking about
making a change but it's hard for me to
like I've always said like they're
really and I do believe this like the
Kate
- losing weight is eating right and you
don't have to exercise to lose weight
but like ads I made in the kitchen but
it definitely helps and I feel like I've
now hit a plateau where I'm gonna lose
all the weight that I can just by just
buddy Tommy better choices and if I want
to lose any more I'm gonna have to start
working out but it's hard for me because
like I really hate lead in my house I
hate leaving Theo like but there are
things for people who hate leaving their
house and hate leaving Theo I'm fully
aware I don't get to it just before I
right before after I got this thing out
of my eye are you trying to get a
beachbody I am okay wait so I really
want to talk about that there is a new
oh my god streaming service cancel your
Netflix cancel your Hulu are you okay by
loving cuz you're falling apart I know
okay someone get her an eyepatch okay
Beachbody unbanned sorry shiver me
timbers no I really did want to talk
about this cuz I did a dance that's in
my living room yesterday and like
honestly at first when I started I like
felt a little stupid and then by the end
I was like endorphins like I felt so
good and you didn't kill your husband
yeah exactly
happy people just don't kill their
husbands okay so Beachbody on demand is
an easy-to-use streaming service that
gives you instant access to a wide
variety of super effective workouts you
can do from the comfort of your living
room and honestly that's where that was
a selling point for me right I hate
leaving Theo I hate just leaving my
house and honestly like seeing all those
skinny girls on SoulCycle but their
sports bras and taking their shirts off
in the front row like not for me just
you know I don't even do that you don't
know okay Theo do the workout as well he
was watching me and I know he was like
what is this girl doing so you can do
like yoga you can do dance class a
bodybuilding weight training but I did
the dance class because that seems like
the most on brand for me and they had
really hot like instructors I was like
cruising through some of the content and
I was enjoying it thoroughly thoroughly
um so our listeners can get a special
free trial membership including their
new 14-day results plan where you can
lose up to nine pounds in the first two
weeks when you text code toast to three
zero three zero three zero 30 30 30 you
will get full access to this entire
platform for free all the workouts the
nutrition information the results to get
you super fat the results plan to get
you super fast results and support
totally free again just text toast to 30
30 30
that's three zero three zero three zero
exciting and honestly like send me
videos of you doing your dance cause
like honestly I felt really stupid for a
while but then I was like loving it
that's so fun I'll come over and do it
with you ya know now I have like this
big new living room like so much
space activities totally so much room
for activities okay
are you ready for our next story
speaking of subscriptions are you ready
for it
okay maybe we should fix you first no
I'm just like slowly done someone said
make yourself cry and it'll go away are
you able to make yourself cry are you
like go like that if I could make myself
crazy I'd be sitting here down a soap
opera that's true okay now take your
lashes I did that over your eyelid over
and hold it for one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten okay let's see
where we are so far so good so far so
good
okay do you think we can get into our
third story
what on Netflix is raising its
subscription prices okay I got so many
news notifications about this yesterday
I don't get news notifications do you
recommend it I do but are you the type
of person who likes to clear your
notifications once you're done with them
like I never like I don't like having
notifications like that in my
notification center yeah I have a lot I
never go to my notification center like
it's not my homescreen and then when I
open my phone they're gone okay
Netflix is raising prices in the US as
the streaming service invests heavily in
new programs so our big question of
who's gonna pay Netflix is debt and pay
for all this original programming for us
all three of the company's plans will
increase in price by one to two dollars
the standard plan $11 for example will
increase to 13 dollars per month the
price hikes will be applied to all
existing members over the next few
months
damn son I just was considering I was
expecting to be grandfathered aren't you
always expecting a grandfather clause
totally I think the whole concept of
grandfathering in is amazing and like
when I'm at a blackjack table and like
usually at like 11:00 or midnight like
they turn all the tables like the
minimum is no longer $5 it's like $15
just so the casino can make more money
but a homegirl you know I'm there since
5:00 a.m. 5:00 a.m. so I'm like I'm
grandfathered in because they move it up
and I'm the only one at the table who's
allowed to still bet $5 mm-hmm Oh about
the grandfathering new members will be
charged a new price immediately it's $8
plan will go up to $9 and it's $14 plan
will go up to $16 a month
Netflix stock spiked 6% congratulations
stock owners to be honest because in the
name of being honest I really felt
casually Carolla
exactly I felt like a year ago or maybe
two years ago there was no price too
high for Netflix like it was the only
thing I needed in my life in the content
both original and licensed was so
premium that I was what is the standard
subscription $8.00 now nine dollars I
would have paid upwards of $20 a month
for it these days with their just like
taking all the good [ __ ] off and nothing
is available anymore Desperate
Housewives is it wasn't even on there
like I find myself going to Netflix less
frequently a day as the days go on that
now like this price increase couldn't be
coming out of worst time for them cuz
I'm already like over them and if I had
my own account that didn't share with
like 7,000 people I might cut like if I
was cutting back I might cut this off I
do own a Netflix now to like hopefully
watch something i watch a bunch of
trailers and then I just give up right
but if they're looking to make money
they should just start doing like five
devices per account I don't know what I
mean yeah because they account that all
of us use is on two TVs in my house my
iPad one or two four TVs at home one two
three four you have is it on your TVs at
my place
I'm sure it's at two TVs on Olivia
that's 11 and I'm sure we're missing
some well we have a family pen so I'm
sure I don't know there must be a device
cap but I would somebody Netflix my iPad
right that's what I'm saying like they
shouldn't this is just too obvious of a
way that you're trying to make money if
you really wanted to make money and it
really should be you shouldn't be like
how iTunes you can only have five
authorized five is too little but like
eight no or two per member mm-hmm we
might still be fine then I don't know I
mean don't give him any ideas cuz
honestly I wouldn't pay the piper for
don't give them any ideas because they
actually listen to my ideas you know you
can skip intro songs if you're been
watching uh yeah I literally tweeted
that at them like a couple years ago and
Kevin Jonas retweeted it and it went so
viral like it was my most like tweet
ever and then like a couple months later
they did it that's so exciting
like I had a direct impact on Netflix
for the second time I like what I also
say viruses and I like watching the
songs because then every as I get more
and more into the show it has new
meaning it depends like Mad Men okay but
the Desperate Housewives one
do-do-do-do-do
so long I knew that I remember as
watching it as a child I remember that
they eventually cut it shorter but they
did I didn't realize how long they took
to get there that intro is torture and
Hulu doesn't let you skip and I found
that to be utterly painful and making no
sense like why do the Egyptian pyramids
come up for Felicity Huffman same I
don't know no sex because it was like
the beginning of civilization early
woman see if you watch it every episode
you'll start to learn things no but
what's really crazy is that they held
the apples and that's really like the
the foundation for all the Housewives
chose well Desperate Housewives is the
foundation I know but not enough people
talk about that is what I'm saying no
but everyone does give credit when it
does come up but how many times are we
going to talk about it you know yeah you
know it's an intro like I'll never I'll
never hate Friday Night Lights or the
osage just cause like that's a bigger
song i'm swatching OC now and it's
banger song and it's not too long no I
feel the same way about Friday night why
it's like that little jingle just like
always makes my heart sing what is it
okay hold on it's like this it's like is
it a song it was just like piano it's
like and if you heard it like you
wouldn't know I can't play it for you
sure okay cuz also know it's bothering
me
no it's bothering me too i watch I did
all of Friday Night Lights theme song
it's not thank you sir let's see yes sir
oh [ __ ] sorry so my first time using a
phone I remember my first time it's just
peaceful dude here we go
[Music]
go Tim Riggins we got the phone but one
[Music]
touchdown Tim Riggins
honestly they should like recreate that
with my version sure wow that's like
everything say sure sure Jam it's like
so rude
ya know but when they say it like that
I'm intending it to be not nice
do you watch the Netflix show friends
from college no I watch season one it
was just like a random show that they
made with like a bunch of actors that
are like kind of famous key and Peele
the less famous one but not they not get
out not Jordan yeah not no but the the
bald one the tall one the tall one yeah
he's a more famous mine
Oh is he I think so the one who did get
out is the shorter one oh and it's like
Sophie oh my a my guys he was part of
key and Peele oh I think you know what I
have honestly no idea who key and Peele
it then
loves can po4 I thought I'd literally
have no idea what what it is what's it a
show I don't have a comedy duo well sure
I like honestly no clue comedy DL so oh
so it was like this Netflix show that I
just like started watching and honestly
was kind of good and the new season just
came out I want to know if like you know
anything about it or heard anything good
no I'm so out of touch keegan-michael
key is the bald one Jordan Peele yes
it's get out okay cool cool okay next
story Kathy Griffin lashes out at Don
Cheadle for not defending her oh my god
I was reading this thread this Twitter
feud on Twitter this morning and
honestly it's hysterical they both
really Kelly Riven doesn't tweet in
English Kathy Griffin proved the
president isn't the only Don she has
beef with after she lambast it Don
Cheadle for being another Hollywood
movie star phony
hours after the miles a head start that
before posted a photo in support of
sleeping giant a group focused on ending
bigotry and sexism in America the 50 row
58 year old comedian lashed out of him
for failing to have her back
oh great Don she tweeted I will never
forgive you for your nasty tweet the day
my smear campaign started you know it
was a [ __ ] smear campaign and you
have never taken a moment to apologize
some liberal you are yes my memory is
long my ex-friend shame on you
I keep a list see
me my memory is long as like the
opposite of my memory is long my
ex-friend Cheadle responded to Griffin
with a simple huh the tweet only served
to further anger the comedian who
resumed berating the actor quote you
don't remember look up your tweets from
May 30th 2017 or May 31st you of all
people just another Hollywood movie star
phony you really had a problem with my
photo question mark you don't know a
smear campaign from the Oval Office the
tabloids the actual news to federal
investigations at the height of the
controversy surrounding the photo
Cheadle defended the comedian's politics
to one Twitter user before according to
any wire writing that pic though she
continued huh you're a dick in real life
but I'll leave it or not I truly hope
what I went through never happens to you
never and if it did I would be the first
one I would be the first in line to
stand up for you get my ass on
television and do everything I could to
defend you and the First Amendment
amendment it's easy Don Cheadle
responded shortly after tweeting that as
far as he was concerned he and Griffin
were never friends but if they were he
would have urged her to not pose for the
provocative photo shoot so he did like a
seven-part tweet and basically what he
said he was like regardless of how you
feel about the president like what you
did was stupid because it's like
obviously it Secret Service is gonna
come after you if you think that like
their think you're trying to plot to
kill the president and he was like
basically she was tweeting at him like
like a parade of tweets just being like
you don't want social justice cuz you
didn't defend me and you didn't go on TV
and he was like if the and then
basically he ends at his thing being
like if the testament of one's
friendship is my ability to go on TV and
defend me something stupid you did like
no we were never friends and it's just
like I can't get I can't get in line
with Kathy Griffin these days because
sometimes like I really don't like I
forgot about what she did and honestly I
don't really care I just didn't never
really liked her as a comedian like
she's not my type of comic but when she
it was in the news a couple of days ago
because she got seated next to Les
Moonves did you see that now she got see
the next to Les Moonves at like Polo
Lounge or like some fancy Hollywood
restaurant and littering me like a whole
scene about her she wouldn't be seated
next to him I mean like live tweeted the
whole thing and honestly he was epic and
I'm like okay great
maybe she's not so terrible but like no
one's talking about her big scandal
anymore except for her right oh god I
forgot about it what I remember from her
is when like a year ago she was like say
to me that video and said yeah cuz drugs
and and let her talk to her on sexy was
a woman and he hates women yeah oh yeah
she that's honestly that's first cross
line like don't talk about any like that
right so that's what I always associate
her with but then she's like still
friends with the Kardashians and North
is going over to her mom yeah so she's
just in this weird like she has this
complex about like obviously she went
through this big scandal and she thinks
like everyone wakes up every day
thinking and talking about the scandal
but literally it's only her I literally
forgot about it and now I said like it
doesn't even seem like a big deal like
it was a stupid thing to do and like did
everyone react like crazy like yeah but
like it was a stupid thing to do and
they want you doing it it wasn't funny
right but and one could also move on
right no it's like everyone has moved on
except for her all she's talking about
is how nobody's moved on from it look
Cathy we have we were almost regretting
it
yeah this next story also don't
disrespect Don Cheadle like I don't
really know Don Cheadle be like I know
he's a highly respected and like well
revered actor and and comic like don't
come for him
no go okay this next story I can't
really look at the screen this was a
Claudia request oh I thought it was an
interesting factoid that was interesting
the world's loneliest frog gets a date
honestly this frog is so ugly you need
to stare at it well it's so cute look at
its green eyes oh I can't look at it oh
my god it's so ugly okay
a frog believed to be the last of his
kind in the world has been granted a
reprieve from Solitude Romeo known as
the world's loneliest frog has spent 10
years in isolation and an aquarium in
Bolivia scientists say they have found
him a Juliet after an expedition to
remote Bolivian cloud forest five so who
say una cos water frogs found in a
stream were captured with the goal of
breeding and reintroducing the
amphibians back into the wild
Teresa Camacho Bo Donnie is the chief of
herpetology okay let me just I'll give a
recap basically you didn't want to hear
about the cheese herpetology at the
museo de historia Naturalis t today
orbán v
income comma city and and she's the
expedition leader in bolivia there was
this like species of frog that was going
instead
and it was literally like one man left
and in order for the for the species to
continue like reproducing he had to [ __ ]
someone and like literally had to kiss a
lot of frogs and he wouldn't he wouldn't
have sex with anyone so they named him
Romeo they made him a Twitter and they
were just like they stuck him in a box
with like all these other girls and was
like have sex and finally after 10 years
the frog had sex with someone and I
think she's pregnant it's so exciting I
can't we got a picture of the Frog Oh
actually it is kind of gross I take it
back
his little legs oh I didn't see that
picture the picture is you
he's furry who wouldn't wanna have sex
with that he honestly a dream man maybe
he'll turn into a prince
totally is that she said Harry its Harry
and Megan I'm so glad now this species
of frog will live to see another day and
honestly that's just a great love story
and some people got texture I see
there's really nothing sadder than
extinction I couldn't agree more
and I just feel like dinosaurs like
never really were here no totally and
then one don't tell Ross Geller there's
nothing sadder than extinction more than
you think about dinosaurs and like they
had to have gone extinct in order for
humans to come so like it's like just
the way it is necessary it's sad when
when animals go extinct due to like
humans being [ __ ] and just killing
them you know yes like I'm telling you
deers are almost gonna die like I know
that they're everywhere but like we just
don't stop killing them I see like a
dead deer once a month like on a road
trip or something and I live in the city
like yeah I think they're okay I don't
know do you ever see their episode of
Extreme Couponing when Captain know when
this guy I've never seen the one episode
actually sorry this was extreme
cheapskates this guy picked up roadkill
on the side of the road and cooked it
for dinner because they can they wanna
pay for food because there's an extreme
cheapskate honest and TLC makes the most
amazing programming like just really
okay really really interesting you know
speaking of amazing programming we gave
you homework last night and it was to
watch fire fraud the documentary on
hooli which obviously I didn't because
I'm just so goddamn busy so what are you
give me this cliff notes for anyone else
who hasn't watched it okay and then
let's recap the dude Rock Jennifer Blume
yes and when she I just caught up okay
and I watched watch what happens live /
- okay but first we need to talk about
the fire festival the dueling
documentaries so if you watch fire fraud
it tells the story of Billy McFarland
how he
how he was raised and what he did before
the greatest scam of all time fire
festival but that he was a scammer you
know running minor scam right up until
this point and it tells the story of how
fire festival got to be what it was all
of the marketing and influencer work
behind it then working with Jerry media
[ __ ] Jerry's agency in order to build
all this hype around they had someone
like an ex-employee they had an
ex-employee of Jerry media who ran point
for this campaign and they also had
Billy McFarland and Hulu is getting like
[ __ ] because apparently they had to pay
him to be in the documentary and someone
made up a figure of two hundred fifty
thousand dollars but that is possibly
not true like he Billy McFarland told
Netflix that Hulu was paying him
$250,000 so what will you pay me oh yeah
as a [ __ ] scam artist sociopath that
he has paid him like 100 share whatever
people be like how could you pay a con
man are you kidding me
I'm so glad we got to see it and the
Netflix one doesn't have Billy McFarlane
in it I'm not interested and his
restitution is like upwards of twenty
five million dollars hundred a twenty
five is like it's nothing it's it's
nothing I'm glad that they paid for him
and it gives them an edge on the Netflix
documentary and Hulu was [ __ ] savage
dropping at four days before the Netflix
start to memory right but it's so this
is always so weird this happens all the
time we're like two of the same movie
come out like two suno whites came out
at the same time a few years no strings
attached and friends-with-benefits came
out literally the same week and it's the
same movie and friendship benefits is so
much better it's so weird like why
doesn't anyone come I think I killed to
death anyone who says that that Natalie
Portman Ashley co-chair movie is better
than the Justin Timberlake Mila Kunis
one no it's not but they're both bad but
it's just friends who like come up with
a pact to like have sex obviously the
girl falls in love and it's like all so
stupid thing so stupid anyways so here's
the synopsis on the drama behind Netflix
and Hulu is dueling fire festival
documentaries the failed fire music
festival which left thousands of
Millennials Chandal in the Bahamas and
its creator sentenced to jail for six
years for fraud is back in the news
after Hulu and Netflix released
competing documentaries in the same week
on Monday Hulu surprisingly dropped its
own documentary about the 2017 music
festival just days ahead of Netflix's
big release a source told Entertainment
Weekly that Hulu felt its documentary
frier fraud which was written by Jenner
first and Julia Willoughby Mason
provided quote enlightening con
ahead of the Netflix totally which it
does they could be alluding to the fact
that Hulu points out that Jerry Media
who was behind the promotion for the
fire festival was also producing the
Netflix documentary about the series no
Hulu is so epic honestly like and I
don't people might not even understand
like the Netflix documentary being
produced by Jerry Media is it might as
well have been produced by Billy with
Garland right like they are so in it
Jerry media effect Jerry was the
minister of propaganda behind the fire
festival right they was the reason he's
making another piece of propaganda right
it was the reason why people even we're
attracted to the festival to begin with
because of their marketing right it was
chocolate festival and so yes they did a
very good they did their job and they
and they did it well but their employee
who speaks on the Netflix talk on the
Hulu documentary lets us know that they
knew well before the [ __ ] show went down
that it was going to be a [ __ ] show they
were posting for when we see on the
ground there's 10 set up Amazon crime
boxes they're posting four days out for
sale for people to come they're still
posting on the day of that it's a normal
thing and that's all and they know that
it's not happening so they like sent
people there and you know they got paid
to do this like and they just did not do
the right thing at any point and there
were so many points at which they knew
that this was gonna happen and they let
it happen now I'm really curious if the
Netflix documentary was which was set to
come out literally in two days if
they're gonna make any changes like now
they've been blown up like an honestly
shame on veidt's like vices so like we
want the real story like they're so
documentary like honest filmmaking like
this is so corrupt you know but I'm
actually really excited to see how they
spin this now yeah I do wonder is that
enough time I don't know how movies
making works but is that enough time to
fix it they could put in probably a
bumper at the end of you know things
that happen since like some just some
text but one of the main interview
subjects of the fire fraud was former
Jeremy the employee or an axe who
alleges the company knew there were red
flags about the festival but do nothing
about it he also claims he was told to
put a search filter on Instagram
flagging words including so you know you
can block comment oh yeah these are the
words that they blocked lineups
performers details info flights fraud
stupid and scam anytime there would be
anything that was quote distasteful or
calling fire out on anything it was
always a matter of go to
that source and eliminate it he says in
the cement I actually have a very
interesting piece of information that I
do think if I said would get me in
trouble but I'm gonna say it anyway but
I'm gonna be very big there's someone
that I know who works for a very big
agency who got fire festival first and
they put together all these proposals
and they did a lot of research and they
said we're not promoting this it's a
scam so they knew just with initial
research like that it wasn't gonna be a
real I just remembered that like someone
literally yeah they were and the person
was telling me they were like it's so
cool like you should do this festival
and then like they did all the research
before taking on the client and they
decided not to take it on because it was
so fraught with so much scam scammy
vibes and it was like a huge agency like
so I guess Jerry media was like the only
person to take the money because
everyone else was smart enough to know
that it wasn't a good client to take on
I just remembered that I got it I didn't
know that I yeah after this you have to
tell me your source yeah and it's legit
Wow yeah I just remembered and then oh
my god so good for that agency like um
and then it's also like the whole
influencer of it all like these
influencers who are just paid so great
this is this is the question now where
does where's the liability like honestly
I don't find there to be any liability
on like Bella Hadid or Emily Ratajkowski
because if someone who's been paid to do
like promote an event that maybe I've
never been at like how it like it's not
your job to make sure that there's
housing available know when to go
through all those flight logistics
information and confirm the band acts
know but when I'm when I'm getting paid
by what appears to be a legitimate
agency it comes with the understanding
that oh we're not gonna try and kill
people or train them on an island of
course but when you're acting on behalf
of an agency and you're taking on a
client that's like taking people
internationally like it's your it's not
just doing the right thing it's it's
borderline illegal ya know you're just
like sending them to guys there's false
advertising but then there's actually
like endangering people yeah like
leaving them on an island with that
can't handle the capacity that has no
food no flights like that's gift or no
hotels because they also chose to do it
on the busiest weekend for the Great
Exuma island
like the Nash family yeah it's like a
huge holiday like bigger than Christmas
for them where like all these tourists
come to people who in there it's I got
over gotta and like a rowing thing yeah
so there's no hotels for like those kids
technically could have gone to like a
hotel on the island for hills there
right by sandals and maybe like had a
decent weekend but there was nowhere for
them to say and there was no fights and
it was just soaked and then also they he
ordered Billy McFarland two million
dollars worth of alcohol from like a
u.s. distributor so they got the alcohol
that also it required him to pay nine
hundred thousand dollars worth of taxes
Bahamian taxes on the import which he
didn't and they just had the bottles
like laying out on the with those ten so
everyone was just drinking so much under
the hot Sun and when they finally go to
the airport they're like all drunk
trying to get on the plane like people
are passing out poor native people where
that's a real victim I have to deal with
these dumb Americans who fell like
honestly I'm really proud of myself
like for not even showing a semblance of
interest I was targeted those ads I'm
similar defender there wasn't a super
motive but whatever like ah that is
something like a lot of people I know
went to like good for me for not falling
into peer pressure but like they had to
watch these dumb Americans like take
over their eyelids get drunk
there was no bathrooms like microrna
potties like more than that they were
the ones who were setting up the
festival we were building at date weeks
before when they knew that it wasn't
gonna work they're working overnight not
sleeping like try like what was there
which was like some semblance of a
staged intense and when at least seven
they were working like tirelessly and
they didn't get paid that is [ __ ]
terrible so they're like really the
victims I have to be honest like the
morons who went like just for the thirst
and the enjoyment of it all like the
people who like the Millennials who went
who make the rest of us look so dumb I
don't feel that badly for them
especially it's like no one was hurt it
was what was it like a $1200 ticket for
the flight and everything yeah like
please you're fine no it was like four
hundreds but there were a villas that
they were selling that were twenty five
thousand dollars but they never existed
he was selling them to pay off debts
like that were coming in before the
before the festival even started
oh my god Wow I need to watch
documentary me too I do not care to me
like it's so crazy then he had um he had
to pay back a loan from some investor
and he didn't have any money so what he
sent out an email to all of the
attendees I saw that cause when I
watched the last 7 minutes because a
bunch of people text me though I have to
walk to last 10 minutes of the fire
festival documentary it shows that your
evil of Eliot to belly aka [ __ ] Jerry
and you know I hate him so like
obviously I ran to Hulu got my account I
literally bought an account on Hilo just
to see this but I caught like the last
five minutes where he was sending out
emails selling tickets to the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show no not that before
fire festival started that he needed to
pay off some debts he emailed all the
attendees saying this will be a cashless
event so you need to upload money to
this bracelet that will be able to UM
you know pay for drinks and stuff we
recommend doing at least three hundred
dollars per day through that they raise
two million dollars of people putting
money on their bracelets for the event
because they couldn't bring cash and he
was able to pay off existing this is
real Ponzi scheme like raising money to
pay off money to raise a goal ever to
have a real festival like yes they were
really working towards it but they
really started the planning maybe three
months before the festival and to put up
a festival on Rhode Island by the way
you need to see their plans for this it
was literally a parking lot off with
sandals
there was no beach it was gravel like it
would have taken someone a real of
Empire planner had said it needed
eighteen months of planning what he was
doing in three months in like he just
they worked really hard for three months
and it didn't even come close they were
using FEMA disaster relief tents those
tents are for disaster oh wait this is
Sarah Macedon prime boxes like he was
just ordering stuff online and sending
it there and I think it's we threw
together a fasting to do literally they
were some of the graphics in the
documentary were funny they were like
grant built like some one of his
henchmen like builds a villa and then
they copy and paste that into search on
Amazon so no results now honestly though
like I really hope that Hulu documentary
does better than the Netflix one and
just because Netflix has never looks
like it's not going to but like I'm I'm
really glad they dropped it first and
that like people are talking about this
one now yeah I think I think they'll
both be pretty well and I think you do
need to see both and ilb now be
interested to see how the Netflix
documentary is framed because it is like
in the context of the people who hate
who made it the success that it was
right now that'll be that would be like
Madoff producing a documentary about the
Madoff scandal right highly unfair I
don't need to see that no no not at all
I don't need to see some more propaganda
Wow honestly just like when justice gets
served it gets [ __ ] served and
honestly I'm so happy right now like
it's really crazy now I'm not happy that
like these poor people homeless but I'm
happy though like you know no justice
for justice no justice hasn't even been
searched no look in my world and it's
like when you think of the fire festival
you think of Oh Billy McFarlane like
scam artist ja Rule maybe a little bit
not even enough yeah but you don't think
of Jerry media and they're the reason
why people were even interested in the
first place yeah and like they did this
shoot this video shoot of like models on
beaches and blah blah blah and it's like
that had nothing that where they did
that video shoot was was it the island
where the that was before they even
secured an island for the festival so
it's just like so [ __ ] fake and
everyone just needs to like do a little
research into if you're gonna be like
going to a festival out of the country
and the hands of like some [ __ ]
idiots no I'll never be the first person
to go to a festival I need at least five
successful festivals before I even think
about purchasing a ticket
I remember Zach sent me the link to fire
festival when it went it um
popped up like when all the models were
posting about it was like the first
trailer and I think he was like he was
like this looks cool and I was like no
no honestly like even if it had turned
out to be like exactly what people said
it was gonna be couldn't have been my
idea of a worse time no couldn't have
been less interested yeah anyways so I
want to talk about Vanderpump rules it
was just a good very good boring episode
unlike nothing really happened but
that's what I like about benefit bro
scene where nothing happens it's just a
good episode there's so many cast
members like I can't keep up ten you see
all the girls I'm watching up inside I
didn't watch they looked so pretty
though they looked I thought the seating
was interesting it was I loved it sassy
was next to F Court Mandy I thought
scheana was misplaced
I thought Kristin was perfect where she
was Sheena should have switched box with
Britney who was sitting in the back row
and and Britney should have been in the
middle front yeah but Britney actually
was the Kourtney Kardashian of the
episode she didn't say much when you say
to her end
to get a word in like with all of those
girls also and Lalla didn't say a lot
either to make my point even bigger did
you see the video that he posted and
Brava posted of the Kardashians walking
the hallway of my son's life and they
were to cut Kourtney off at the end lol
yeah also I agreed with you about Kim's
outfit and her look and I know the whole
thing was terrible
yeah okay let's world look start my
Center purple girls okay happen Stasi
fought with her mom very weird fight
Sassy's post birthday oh yeah on the
stages love Bo I love but when he liked
her gate like he didn't even need her to
apologize that much but like he forgave
her and then when he says news interview
he's like I'm just in love with her
anyone also like thank you for not
making her apologize so much like when
people do that like when you make a
drunk was taking they make you apologize
like a hundred where it's like where
does this come from like you want to sit
down right now like and and therap eyes
if it's not to talk about it it's not a
pattern it's not necessary but it is a
pattern for her but like he's also like
telling her okay you got to figure it
out get it together but like I'm not
gonna like try and be your therapist
right now and he was being so cute
watching her do her Skype chat with her
publishers oh my god he was being what's
okey about like is it a memoir I don't
think she said it's a manifesto
okay like a guide how to I'll let you
know when I read yeah cuz you know I
will um then Sheena went on the date
with Robbie Hayes and honestly I just
couldn't sup cringing the whole time
like and I didn't know who was making me
cringe more and honestly the whole time
I thought he was Adam they look exactly
like I was so confused the fact that he
turns with Adam is so weird the fact
that they made it like a fake episode of
The Bachelor was hilarious hilarious and
then when they said when they pan to the
girls at the Smashing of the plates they
were like she Katie said it's you like
Sheena is literally on her own season of
the bats are just between these two men
it's so weird it's so weird that she's
just openly like yeah I'm going on a
date with this guy cuz Adam doesn't like
me and they're friends right and I
thought and I guess this makes sense now
because now when I think back a couple
months when they weren't filming
everyone was like there's so much
regulation
Sheena and I'm just like we're not
dating we're not dating and I thought
she was being annoying and she wants it
no they're not to you but now she is
dating Adam correct oh like they have
all these couple pictures on Instagram
that's what I'm saying but she's denying
it whether I don't know
I don't know she's I don't know and I'm
such a weird like he came in so weird
yeah also we need to talk about the
Billy of it all the Billy Lee right she
was in the staff meeting and like was
coming for Kristin Jodie like out of
nowhere she's in the staff meeting at a
restaurant that she works out and
Kristin
doesn't even work there yeah so
essentially she's saying Christine can't
come in as a customer cuz she steps off
our DJ well you have DJ's mentally
unstable that was so weird and like it
was like she just wanted to talk about
Kristin so she's like pulled Kristin out
if she just wanted to talk and then it
seems like next week they want to make
it seem to Lisa like see you next
Tuesday isn't popular because of James
it's popular because they know someone
from Vanderpump rules is gonna be there
and people want to come so they do GNO
instead of see you next Tuesday to be
like hey hey Lisa I'm a girl I'm gonna
bring all the other girls we're gonna
make just as much money as James maybe
even more and I was like a brilliant
concept and I'm sure and by the way that
was the smartest thing that they could
have done and I'm so excited for next
week's episode because when they when
the business owners are saying like
James brings the money and it's true
like they can't deny that but it is
because they know that it's a big night
and if you and you live in LA or you're
in LA and you want to go to it you want
to go to sur not for the great cuisine
but for the hopes of seeing a banner
from pearls character you don't know
when they're gonna be there so the fact
that there's a to Senate event where
James is guaranteed to be at probably
Raquel and then maybe some other cast
mates for filming like scheana will
waitress or some [ __ ] like it's a it's a
detraction it has nothing to do with the
fact that James is this amazing DJ just
the fact that they're scheduled to
talent to be there and it's annoying I
think just heard many times and no one's
there except for Peter and like that's
annoying right so go down the girls for
making it like for breaking the
distinction right and doing the work
like you know what you don't want James
here fine but now someone else has to
fill that void and and they're gonna do
it looks so fun so I guess they did gee
I know with like the banner from pearls
girls and Billy goes off saying like I
can't believe you didn't invite me
uh you're transphobic because it was
girls night out and I saw one clip and
Katie was AK what are you talking about
she wasn't invited cause she's not a
cast right it's it's it's not girls
Hannah it's relevant that's makes
relevant girls night tonight right like
Raquel wasn't there now that she would
be Raquel is just as probably more of a
cast more of a cast member you have then
Billy right I thought that was weird
and then Billy says something to Lisa
about like that she can't choose to be
trans but like Katie can choose to be
fat oh oh you're right I did see that
yeah oh that that looks that looks rough
well I never really um like cared for
Billy because she's not a cast member
no and and now a little bit with the
podcast with Stassi last year and there
was like a little bit drama around that
so she got a couple episodes but I don't
come she in
opening credits yeah cuz they'd like $30
yeah everyone who's ever stepped foot on
the show yeah because in there right
I don't know it'll be interesting and
and she used to be friends with wah wah
and then I know this season she fights
with Lala so I'm just curious what
happened you know it's like she wanted a
storyline and there was so little to
grasp at like she just started yelling
right I'm actually really excited for
next week because I saw that unfold on
Twitter where she was yeah they've all
posted picture like so much fun Gino
Tuesday it's gonna be the new Tuesday
and then she does brunch with Billie
remember like that I think that I don't
know that on the show but she did that
in real life good great great
the girls Marmont turn up and vibe and
it was loving watch habits I've la know
same premium did you see in the
Kardashians episode how much Andy was
sweating and I'm getting hip was wiping
his up early no I didn't see like every
time they pan to the Kardashian so Andy
could wipe is left and they pan back to
him and they caught like the tail end of
it I'll be I was hyper aware of how hot
he was it must be this Newton this LA
studio that has like hotter lights here
so I was wondering if he was also hot
what was the question that you said came
watered great oh the very end yes the
whole time she wasn't fazed by anything
when he was like squash the beef Taylor
strip she was like oh I'm over it she's
really very chill
at the end he was like open they threw
the fat plead the fifth to Kim who was
really be stuck in an elevator with
Taylor Swift she didn't make a thing or
Drake and Larry she was just like Taylor
Swift she that was the only question
that shook her because Kiki do you love
me and like the blinds have things to
say that's the craziest part I know
hidden in plain sight talk about hidden
play inside Kiki do you love me I know
also I want to talk about one more thing
about Vanderpump pearls that I really
need the storyline of Katie being fetch
like stop being a thing because like
homeworlds not that like just like I'm
talking about like to the naked eye
size-wise like she's not fat right like
I was looking at pictures of arm watch I
was like I was like looked amazing I'm
like why is this why is this now like a
thing like like as if it's a fact like
you can't call Katie like she's not yeah
and they're all acting like she is it
it's like a mean thing to say like this
[ __ ] first of all she's not just facts
yeah that is like a mean word but like
it's also you can be fat and you can be
skinny Kate it's not bad
sorry I just want to say that um what do
you think about the Kardashians
what do you think about the dynamic
about the Kourtney and the Khloe of it
all um I I wouldn't have noticed I think
Kourtney spoke more than then I thought
she was gonna be somewhat
said like so to me I was like oh no
she's been poisoned your mind she spoke
a good amount for Courtney okay um I
thought it was really cute I needed more
it was the only episode of watch what
happens live where and he's not cutting
everyone off at their answers and Kim
was answering a few things really slowly
and that and I'm sure no he was kill it
like dying yeah he but because they
didn't put any of their like Bravo stuff
in there they had more time in the
episode you know he didn't do his usual
like here's this would you know so she
had the time they wasted too much time
on like that question about plastic
surgery like how do you feel when people
get plastic surgery to look like you and
she literally took like four minutes
yeah that's so true that wasn't even an
interesting question it's like four
minutes out of like a 13 minute episode
right honestly I was just like I need to
watch the after show same but I don't
even know where to watch it Robert to be
calm mm-hmm okay I just loved it like I
loved seeing them together they're a
really are like so not contrived and
like every celebrity comes on with like
a an answer that they practiced in media
training and this publisher says not
what to say I really feel like they just
sat down and that was it I feel like
they do that all they don't have they
are like the best media trainers like no
one could teach them about media no you
know yeah and they really have just made
a career off of being like honest and
when they tried to like contrived [ __ ]
like yeah when they tried member when
they filmed that scene of Chris and Kim
in the car and Kim was like talking
about some of her fears about Kris
Humphries yes and if everyone found out
that it was after the divorce but they
had filmed it and cut and pasted it to
make it seem like she was having doubts
like they and they got blown up and they
learned their lesson and they never did
that [ __ ] again yeah so now they really
are like oh open and honest as they can
be and I love that agreed I need to
watch also the banner from pearls kids
but obviously caught up on New Jersey
which is like slowly turning into like
the greatest season of Jersey and like
the past ten years what are your
thoughts
I'm just so I'm sofa Klimt why because
my stands on the show are Margaret and
Melissa and in real life I love them and
they have decided to align themselves
with Jackie and I just don't see it and
I don't like her and I kind of like
Jennifer and I agree with Jennifer
I like Jennifer and I like Jackie and I
kind of agreed with Teresa but like good
I'm good on Jackie for apologizing but
she's just coming in like so abrasive
and like that's the worst way to come in
when you're a housewife I don't know why
I don't feel like it's too abrasive she
said
one thing which by the way was the thing
that we were all thinking I wasn't
thinking at first oh I was if you can
control if a woman can control her
husband then how come your man's in
prison I don't think she was saying
though that woman can control her
husband I think she was saying Melissa
can control Joe no she was saying a
woman can control her husband and she
just needed to be shot down because it's
not
Melissa's place to manage Joe when it
comes to Teresa but I do wish that
Dolores and Jackie had both just shut
the [ __ ] up because it's not their
business right Melissa in Georgia so I
have to stop having like family
conversations in a big group right
that's it
but I love Dolores I thought that event
was like so cute and so sweet and like
all the women just like helping out I
loved it and Prive you know Bravo
inspring yeah so like they're always
showing up in their t-shirts I thought
that was just like such a cute little
brand integration agreed they also need
to like bring Danielle around more
because right now it's like Margaret is
fighting with Danielle
Dolores hate sing L sent Danielle are
best friends right and also it's like
Teresa ending L our best friends yet
Danielle like gets mad at Margaret for
even just like entertaining Dolores like
wait Danielle gets mad at me like kind
to or just open to Dolores meanwhile
Danielle doesn't get mad at Teresa for
being best friend since sue at high
school just the double standard I can't
even but I'm ready for Dolores and
Margot to become closer especially
because of Danielle yeah and that's
gonna happen in this week's episode
which I'm really like Dolores me too and
what heard when they've been to go visit
that site and her son said about how
about Dolores was so sweet someone just
said I can't stand Jackie I'm like
that's [ __ ] rude no I just I can't I
want to like her because I met her and
she was lovely and Melissa and Margaret
love her and I love Melissa Margaret and
I trust them but I don't know I guess
really like Jennifer and I wasn't
expecting to also seeing she's such an
interesting culture I'm learning so much
about Turkish Catholics and who knew and
I think the way that people are talking
about her is like not so nice like with
her house and then saying it was a
arranged marriage yeah I like her and
she's done nothing literally bit but
been so nice to everyone and she'll find
it funny and she's so rich and she's
like says stuff that's funny
and everyone is just always so filtered
like when even when she was in Oklahoma
and she was definitely being like
offensive about country but it was funny
like whatever
no totally like honestly I hope she gets
a second shot I think that she will and
I mean the house definitely helps the
house definitely helps and you could
like see when they pan to her house like
she obviously bought like a like a plot
in a neighborhood that like wasn't so
nice because it houses next to her like
tiny and she lives in a mansion that
takes up the whole walk totally I mean
she can see the city from her backyard
there was one more thing I wanted to say
about housewives hmm give me a second
okay tell me the names of everyone
Melissa
Margaret Danielle Theresa Dolores
Jennifer Jackie maybe it was it ding
Allan her wedding it was something I
don't remember Dolores and Frank and the
son know the newspaper article no like a
good point
damn let's try if you think I have
another one of these moments in a while
which is like really annoying my brain
is great yeah Skillshare is really
working for you truly um I can't
remember whatever whatevs
maybe it'll come back to you what else
is there anything else that we need to
recap no but I finally feel like imma
call now there was like a moment where I
was like so behind on all my shows and
it really gives me terrible anxiety and
like you know what we need like a
schedule someone needs to put together a
full like schedule of what's on every
night because I just forget and I didn't
remember a day but gravel keeps changing
it Jim yeah and like Sunday Monday
benefit rules and anything being on on
Monday is just not gonna work for me
because the three-hour bachelor I mean
now it's two hours now but no doubt it's
to our bachelor and Vanderpump rules how
was your wedding walkthrough yesterday
oh it was good so it was so crazy
actually wasn't as far as daunting
wedding tasks to go it wasn't that bad
but um it's just planning a wedding you
guys I don't know how you all do it I
know and you're really in like the crux
of it now yeah and I guess it's actually
should be getting easier from here on
out because now it's like out of my
hands like I've made all the decisions
um now you just have to let the chips
fall where they may
like have you did you have a checklist I
actually had a checklist that I found
online and it was incredibly helpful
well I'm using Zula for like everything
for my wedding website and my registry
and so they keep me like in check and I
look at like other website said what
other people are doing just to see if I
should be doing the same thing you know
they have like the budget and like all
that stuff I found those little tools
like a really helpful ya know they take
the stress out of wedding planning with
free wedding websites your dream wedding
registry afford will save the dates and
invitations easy to use planning tools
they conveniently manage everything
online in one place and for someone
who's like very organization you know
friendly friendly that is very important
to me just to be able to see things and
you know coordinate with my planner to
start your friends you see things for
what they truly are which is to start
your free wedding website and also get
$50 off your registry unzila go to Zola
comm slash toast that 0l a.com slash
toasts to start your free wedding
website and also get $50 off on your
registry on Zola go to Zola comm slash
toast it really has helped me I'm not
gonna lie there's so many toasters
getting married like just I mean the
group toasters getting appetizers
getting hits there's two groups actually
and every time I like to a meeting Reid
I just like see they're all have like
such a nice fiance's like they're just
like making nice lives for themselves
it's so cute
so for all you Bright's out there Zola
calm slash toast I really highly
recommend it I don't know what I would
do if I had to like go it on my own and
do everything like separate how do
people get married before the internet
well actually it was less pressure to
make like Instagram bubble moment and
have like a flower wall so I guess
that's good too but like I honestly like
I relied so much especially cuz I was
the first person in the family to get
married like we didn't know anything
like I literally just would Google stuff
it's so I know I'm gonna live you're so
lucky to have such an encyclopedia of
knowledge next to you that's true I just
can't believe like how many people like
go through the wedding planning process
and it's so hard like and then I can't
like there's so many people who get
married and like go through the wedding
planning process and like don't talk
about it and complain
no I how do we know cuz then some people
say that wedding planning Oh people say
it's so hard but it's really great nope
I've never heard anyone say it was hard
before I started planning my wedding
everyone was always like it's the
greatest time your life and joy are
[ __ ] liars [ __ ] liars no the only
time is that that's a greatest part of
your life that you should enjoy is the
actual wedding but the leading up just
embrace the treachery like if you're
gonna try and do the whole thing with a
smile it'll make it so much harder no
there's
think about wedding planning that's
enjoyable like there are things that
make it easier like Zula but it's
[ __ ] tough stuff it's tough stuff and
it's masters like this cute thing you
know that's the hardest part yeah that's
what these are like
when people are like house wedding
planning I I don't even pretend I'm like
it's [ __ ] torture no like when people
used to be like those people are knowing
they'll like this you know what suggests
venue flowers and then you just want to
sock those people in the face because
you know those people aren't married
because if they were they wouldn't ask
I believe my engage friends I talk about
anything but the wedding cuz I know
right I would never ask anyone how's
wedding planning something unless like
we were in a conversation and I had
nothing to say right and they were
engaged but like I'll never forget just
like going to parties be like did you
get you jest yeah and like look I just
like would fart like out of anxiety like
[ __ ] off like I don't ask people that
it's honestly it's now a rude question
no asking a woman her age is the same as
asking her if she's gotten her wedding
dress yet hey same as a senior house
wedding planning going it's the same as
me or what are your wedding colors
what's your wedding fruit like I can't I
think you guys have to watch fire fried
on Hulu like this is so crazy and also
to make sure I'm that like now people
need to get smarter you know there was
that weird sales rep gets smarter get
harder in the nick of time there is a
thread in the toasters about like did
any of you go to fire festival and know
people said yeah a lot of people either
date are new people who did and we just
we have to get smarter and we need to
now know when you know there's being
there's propaganda being thrown our way
if the toast was around I remember what
I wanted to say about the Real
Housewives of New Jersey so I got a DM
and I got to see em with a tip and she
won't remember nay not remain anonymous
and I get Tim's with tips all the time
sometimes they're very good like the day
that Karlie Kloss and Jared Kushner got
married I got a tip and we posted about
it and we were the first people and we
were totally right I also got a tip that
Priyanka Chopra was pregnant which is
proving to be not true but I want to say
the tips just in case they come to
fruition they filmed in New Jersey
reunion
and someone said that in the reunion
Teresa is announcing that she has a
boyfriend and that her and Joe we're
getting divorced but I don't know if
it's sure but I just want to say that
doesn't sound like Teresa no also if it
was like one of the hair and makeup
people are when the audio people
would've leaked it like those shed that
[ __ ] always gets leaked yeah but people
they there have been reports that she
has a boyfriend for so long like which
even if someone leaked it I wouldn't
believe it like
she says it herself but I don't think
she would do it at a ring and that opens
her up to so much criticism like I think
she would do is sit down with people or
I should check yeah Oh totally you know
I actually I'm gonna say I don't believe
this okay I'm with you I'm going just in
case I want to put it out there okay
very cool thank you guys so much for
being here also if you were listened to
yesterday if you were watching live on
yesterday's episode we lost our feed
like with two minutes left if you want
the other two minutes the audio was
totally fine and it's uploaded to the
podcast app if you care um if you wanna
listen to our new patreon episode which
honestly i really suggest that you do
eight dollars a month for patreon it's
really just like one less coffee if
you're sad that the toast is ending
right now like go join patreon you'll
have over 25 episodes of premium ask on
you can get those episodes in your
podcast app and you can join the toast
after dark group which is a premium
subgroup but thank you guys for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube and we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found it's been an absolute pleasure
hanging out with you I'm hungry bye bye
you